in this video we're going to introduce
ourselves to the idea of partial
pressure due to ideal gases and the way
to think about it is imagine some type
of a container
and you don't just have one type of gas
in that container you have more than one
type of gas
so let's say you have gas one
that is in this white color and
obviously i'm not drawing it to scale
and i'm just drawing those gas molecules
moving around you have gas 2 in this
yellow color you have gas 3 in this blue
color
it turns out that people have been able
to observe that the total pressure in
this system and you could imagine that's
being exerted on the inside of the wall
or if you put anything in this container
the pressure the force per area that
would be exerted on that thing is equal
to the sum of the pressures contributed
from each of these gases or the pressure
that each gas would exert on its own so
this is going to be equal to
the partial pressure due to gas 1
plus the partial pressure due to gas 2
plus the partial pressure due to gas 3.
and this makes sense mathematically from
the ideal gas law that we have seen
before remember the ideal gas law tells
us that pressure times volume is equal
to the number of moles times the ideal
gas constant times the temperature
and so if you were to solve for pressure
here just divide both sides by volume
you get pressure is equal to n
r times t
over volume
and so we can express both sides of this
equation that way our total pressure
that would be our total number of moles
so let me write it this way n
total
times the ideal gas constant times our
temperature in kelvin divided by the
volume of our container and that's going
to be equal to
so the pressure due to gas 1 that's
going to be the number of moles of gas 1
times the ideal gas constant times the
temperature the temperature is not going
to be different for each gas we're
assuming they're all in the same
environment divided by the volume and
once again the volume is going to be the
same they're all in the same container
in this situation
and then we would add that
to the number of moles of gas 2 times
the ideal gas constant which once again
is going to be the same for all the
gases times the temperature divided by
the volume and then to that
we could add the number of moles of gas
3 times the ideal gas constant times the
temperature divided by the volume now i
just happen to have three gases here but
you could clearly keep going and keep
adding more gases into this container
but when you look at it mathematically
like this you can see that the right
hand side
we can factor out the rt over v and if
you do that you are going to get n1
plus
n2
plus
n3
let me close those parentheses times
rt
rt
over v and this right over here is the
exact same thing as our total number of
moles if you say the number of moles of
gas 1 plus the number of moles of gas 2
plus the number of moles of gas 3 that's
going to give you the total number of
moles of gas that you have in the
container so this makes sense
mathematically and logically
and we can use these mathematical ideas
to answer other questions or to come up
with other ways of thinking about it for
example let's say that we knew that the
total pressure
in our container due to all of the gases
is four
atmospheres
and let's say we know that the total
number of moles
in the container is equal to
8
moles
and let's say we know that the number of
moles of gas 3 is equal to 2
moles can we use this information to
figure out what is going to be the
partial pressure due to gas 3. pause
this video and try to think about that
well one way you could think about it is
the partial pressure due to gas 3
over
the total pressure
over the total pressure is going to be
equal to
if we just look at this piece right over
here it's going to be this it's going to
be the number of moles of gas 3 times
the ideal gas constant times the
temperature divided by the volume and
then the total pressure
well that's just going to be this
expression so the total number of moles
times the ideal gas constant times that
same temperature because they're all in
the same environment divided by that
same volume they're in the same
container and you can see very clearly
that the rt over v is in the numerator
and the denominator so they're going to
cancel out
and we get this idea that the i'll write
it down here the partial pressure due to
gas 3
over
the total pressure
is equal to
the number of moles
of gas 3
divided by the total
total number of moles and this quantity
right over here
this is known as the mole fraction let
me just write that down it's a useful
concept and you can see the mole
fraction can help you figure out what
the partial pressure is going to be so
for this example if we just substitute
the numbers we know that the total
pressure
is four
we know that the total number of moles
is eight we know that the moles of the
number of moles of gas three is two
and then we can just solve we get let me
just do it right over here i'll write it
in one color
that the partial pressure due to gas 3
over 4 is equal to 2 over 8 is equal to
1 4. and so you can just pattern match
this or you can multiply both sides
by 4
to figure out that the partial pressure
due to gas 3 is going to be
1 and since we were dealing with units
of atmosphere for the total pressure
this is going to be 1 atmosphere and we
would be done